but we'll begin this morning with the
historic political paralysis in
Washington the house begins a third day
deadlocked over choosing a house Speaker
after Republican leader Kevin McCarthy
failed to secure enough support in a
sixth that's right a sixth vote and
despite late night negotiations there
are no signs an agreement is close among
divided Republicans Scott McFarland has
been at the Capitol throughout this
entire standoff getting a close-up look
and he joins us now Scott good morning
Adriana good morning to you embattled
house Republican leader Kevin McCarthy
is Frozen in a stalemate with a faction
of 20 fellow House Republicans denying
him the votes he needs to be speaker
leaving Capitol Hill Wednesday night
after losing his house speakership
election for the sixth time Kevin
McCarthy said he plans to hold on for
now do you have a deal with those guys
right now
a revolving door of back room meetings
and a marathon second day of votes a
speaker has not been elected couldn't
break the Log Jam I'm ready to vote all
night all week all month and never for
that person the group of 20 Republican
defectors which has criticized McCarthy
for not being conservative enough which
has accused him of breaking promises
wasn't swayed by a request from Donald
Trump that they backed McCarthy and not
turn a great Triumph into a giant and
embarrassing defeat even having my
favorite President call us and tell us
we need to knock this off I think it
actually needs to be reversed the
president needs to tell Kevin McCarthy
that sir you do not have the votes and
it's time to withdraw
and with that I yield thank you former
speaker Nancy Pelosi blasted the
dysfunction thank God they weren't in
the majority of January 6th
that was the day you had to be working
the most to stay off what was happening
to save our democracy the standoff
threatens disruptions especially to the
newly elected house members that haven't
been sworn in they might have difficulty
Fielding questions from their
constituents who might need help with
Social Security checks passports or
veterans benefits there could be a point
at which it does mean something to the
constituents that we serve whether we
can engage in case work on their behalf
and one Wisconsin Republican says he was
denied a needed security briefing I'm
informed by how security that
technically
I don't have a clearance because he's
not an official member of Congress until
a speaker is chosen
the house stands adjourn until noon
tomorrow
it was a chaotic end of the night with
Republicans barely passing a measure
just to call it a night and adjourn and
go home but the question this morning is
what concessions can or must Kevin
McCarthy offer to these 20 Republicans
before the house reconvenes here midday
Tony
yeah they meet again at High Noon we
better hope there's not a National
Emergency they need to react to before
then Scott thank you very much